كل شبر من الراحة من
القصف الروسي هنا يأتي بتكلفة باهظة
ما هطلت عليه مدينة خاركيف الثانية
الآن
[موسيقى]
حسنًا ،
أعلنت أوكرانيا هنا تحرير روسكا لوزيفا منذ
أكثر من أسبوعين ، لكنها
ليست بهذه البساطة أبدًا
تلك القرى الصغيرة التي كانت قبل الحرب
كانت أماكن لا تلاحظ القيادة
فيها ، أصبحت الآن
ساحات القتال الرئيسية للدفاع عن مدن حيوية
مثل خاركيف
بينما لا يزال القتال لحماية حكيم
محتدماً مع كل خطوة سريعة وحذرة
بسبب الألغام ، فإن حدود روسيا الآن على
بعد تسعة أميال فقط
هل فكرت يومًا  أفضل نادي لك في
روسيا هو ثلاثة أشهر تقريبًا
[موسيقى]
ولكن القوات الروسية أقرب إلى
ذلك في الغابة عبر الحقل
فوق هذا الجدار الذي يقولون إنه
كثيرًا في الليل
تحاول مجموعات الاستطلاع الروسية الانتقال
إلى القرية ، حيث
تكون القرية الصغيرة التالية  يتم القتال
حولها وهذا هو المكان الذي
لا يمكن أن يفشل
فيه دفاع هاركيف في تقديم الهدايا الأكثر فعالية للولايات المتحدة في بعض
أيادي أوكرانيا الأصغر.
يقول ن إنه لم يكن يتوقع أن يكون في
سن 19 عامًا ، فقد كان خائفًا من
قصف [الموسيقى] هنا مستمر على الرغم من أنه
يبدو أن كل مكان قد تعرض بالفعل
للإصابة ،
هذا هو متطوعو الدفاع المحليون
ومهندسو البرمجيات الاقتصاديون
الممولون في الغالب من دليلنا المليونير الزراعي في
روسيا  احتلال قصير لم يخطط
أبدًا لترك أي شيء ذي قيمة هنا ،
لقد استوعبوا zeds في شاحنة مليئة بأجهزة
التلفاز للنهب ، يرون أننا نعيش بشكل أفضل
ولا يعتقدون
حتى أن هناك شيئًا ما خطأ معهم
وليس معنا ، أنت تعلم أنهم
يعتقدون ذلك
لأن أمريكا  يعطينا كل شيء
مجانًا ويكرهوننا لذلك
ويسرقوننا ويقتلوننا
رجالًا ونساءً تعلموا الشجاعة خلال ثلاثة أشهر
فقط بعد معرفة
الخوف عن قرب ، كانت اللحظة العضلية في
اليوم الخامس من الحرب التي
كنت فيها  لقد
جمعنا
المركز الطبي في إحدى
نقاط أه في كييف وأم الآن الكاميرا
وأخبرنا أن
القوات الخاصة الروسية
ستأتي وتحاول مهاجمتنا من الخلف.
لم نتدرب على فعل هذا أه
لم نكن مسلحين للقيام
بهذا أه كانت أكثر اللحظات رعباً
بالنسبة لي لكنك نجوت ،
نعم ، لقد نجينا من
الجميع ، لقد جعلتها بخير
وأه أعتقد أن هذه هي اللحظة التي
قتلت أه الخوف
في داخلي ، يوقفون عدوًا
يثبت ببطء أنه غير كفء لأنه غير أخلاقي من
خلال وضع قيمة لا تصدق على
أصغر بقع من أرضهم
نيك بايتون والش سي إن إن روسكا لوزوفو
أوكرانيا